hello everyone and welcome back to
gamespot live
i'm richie and today we are going to be
playing some warzone there was a massive
update between warzone and call of duty
black ops cold war
so i'm going to try out the new map and
see what it's all about
it is rebirth island let's get into it
thank you guys for being here i'm going
to switch over to the game now
let me know if you guys can hear me okay
um
so i got a few rounds in early on and
it's hot this is it's so fun so i'm just
going to jump right into it
if you guys are pumped leave a little
like on the video if you're watching on
youtube
keep it up in the chat i see you guys
i'll be here chatting with y'all
all right hearing me good great let's
just get into it so i unlocked all the
stuff man this update was
massive uh there was a lot of freebies
and the new battle passes here
and i don't like all those green dots up
top so i cleared everything out and i'm
ready to begin
i'm gonna be playing with some randoms
because the only way you can play
rebirth island currently
is through uh uh resurgence trios so
it's the game mode in battle royale on
the new small map that you can respawn
it's pretty hectic and despite like
respawning the games
still last or the games are still really
short short matches so let's get into it
what's up chad okay great you guys hear
me see me what's up ethan
welcome welcome welcome you guys
thanks for being here this update is
available now
so it means so much that you're here
watching me instead of playing it
yourself
all right got some randoms here might
mute them to avoid
excessive swearing and bad call-outs so
let's go
i can paint i know how to ping love from
pakistan what up hey
elion i'm gonna say your name wrong but
thank you for being here
who's my favorite character this season
so far i really like stitch and i've
always liked adler because
if you guys haven't played the cold war
campaign he's uh he's og
i'm going to switch over to my gaming
headset
and let's get it going
get yourself the proper warm-up okay now
i can't hear myself but the important
thing is i can hear the game
here's the rebirth map you guys
okay just the warm-up round let's go
q-ro hello welcome
here's a little sneak peek it's just uh
it's mob of the dead it's alcatraz
you guys remember when alcatraz was in
tony hawk 4 it's the same thing baby
i need a skateboard does it lag i
haven't had any lags in rebirth yet
after the update i did have some lags in
multiplayer on the playstation 5.
um that's it
reese i'm not going to read your name
but yes resurgence currently is only
playable
uh um rebirth is only playable through
resurgence i believe right now
i tried to get into a random game of
battle royale and it was
only for dance was coming up now we do
this for real okay here we go hopefully
my
teammates aren't bad hopefully i'm not
bad but we're gonna have some fun look
here's the map
very small over here on the over here on
the side somewhere
or was it maybe this side hey maybe it's
not in every match
uh there was a gondola that took you
like from here to here forget where it
is
oh well look at oh look at that we're
all stitched
how do you play rebirth you got to play
the resurgence game mode
i'm the squad leader no no no no no
on newgen bro my age is 69.
wait who's stitch all right i gotta get
into this guys
excuse me while i drop in i'm just gonna
okay homeboy pink blue let's go oh
hot drop it's always a hot drop
right away this guy's a real mvp right
here
what a hot drop
get a dub for the stream all right
that's that's the hope they're gone i
need that guy's armor asap oh he took my
armor
whoa whoa whoa
another one another one
you see but it's okay i'm
that was a very hot drop but we respond
in this mode so thank goodness
any new guns yes there are fat cat from
sweden asks if there are any new guns
yes there are there are two we've got um
at launch anyway
we've got the gorza assault rifle
and the mac 10. a few more will come
later there's a
street sweeper shotgun and of course the
melee sledgehammer and the melee katana
so i don't have those yet the only thing
i do have unlocked is the mac
10. jesus is crazy all right gotta find
the homies
they're all over here bad dude
oh goodness oh come on oh he had
automatic okay i almost had him this is
loco
all right echo we'll see you later
oh the guns that have been implemented
from cold war into
war zone have their own mechanics from
war
i'm sorry from cold war so they play a
little differently but it's all you know
it all works for the meta
so far from what i've seen oh my god
okay that was a really rough start these
guys are carrying me not a good sign
nonetheless they are alive let's get
this dead
[Music]
i need something better than this
handgun and i don't i'm not really good
with the dragon off
oh they're over there
pop your head up pop your head up come
on
oh it's the it's the raphica it's a
three round burst one
all right we're chasing us
okay i need that now give me something
this is the
look at that that's one of the why did i
pick that up
there you go uh it's the milano from
cold war if you guys have been playing
cold war multiplayer heck yeah
you'll be familiar with this did you
hear that there's an rc xd
on the ground right now this is crazy
although those have been those have been
in war zone for a little bit now
i hate those things he's so annoying
pick it up get to see
the area watch the skies where where
where you're lying
all right these guys are good i'm
confident we can get far
i need armor now i needed it yesterday
what's this
nope locked there's ammo that's good
good armor yes
i will gladly take this bison how do you
guys say it
byzon oh this guy needs armor too
reminds me of cod mobile is that true is
this uh you're getting those vibes i'll
take that dead silence if you don't know
how he took it okay
you know i'm gonna give him the good
stuff because uh they're they appear to
be better than me already
okay we gotta watch for the smoke
there's a lot going on already dudes
this is a hectic game mode
but these guys are good so far i'm happy
with them do they keep modern warfare
gameplay or
change it to cold war it's um when it
comes to war zone it's still
like generally the modern warfare
gameplay you're familiar with
crap contact contact okay
there's two i'm surrounded boys
why is it always me why me god
well okay cold 45 my homies are down
here now hopefully they uh
they they clean up
george blunt
oh no uh you don't see that match took
like five minutes
and we took tenth like what let's try
this again i was just a warm-up round
those guys were good i was undeserving
of them battle royale see the only way i
can play
rebirth is resurgence so let's go
i played like four or five rounds and i
got a care package i gotta load out once
like this mode barely
even allows for it hey
brandon hernandez in the chat what's up
man he's on my side he's like it's all
good richie you're just warming up
it's good to see you man do i have my
own channel oh um
yeah um i don't use a watch it says um
i'll say hi in the chat this is the
account you can find me at but
all my work is on gamespot.com that's
where you can find me
speaking of which we've got a few videos
that i've made
made recently for call of duty's most
broken guns if you guys have seen that
you probably recognize
me or at least my voice those are mine
please enjoy them
uh and leave comments for other broken
guns you want to see if we make a part
three
and we've also got a ton of expert
reacts
uh if you guys been seeing those lately
we got an expert reacts to
like almost every recent call of duty
game he takes a look at the guns that
are
in cold war even escape from tarkov and
uh
he breaks them down and sees and sees
how accurate they are in gameplay you
gotta
check out those videos if you haven't
those are fun
all right that's just the warm-up zone
not polished bro hmm oh looks good okay
no i don't do reviews i i just do mostly
call of duty stuff
all right
okay we got some we got some
questionable names for my teammates here
but uh hopefully that just means they're
they're good at this game
oh that's really nice my voice is lovely
how can i say your name i don't want to
i don't want to incorrectly say that
zaluku nope um i tried
cold war movement is fire says time to
kick this off
sir joe i don't know i've been seeing a
lot of
like and i get it but i've been seeing a
lot of uh
dislike for cold war i think over
because people like modern warfare
better
not that cold war on its own is a bad
game but coming from modern warfare
it was a tough one why am i always a
squad leader
battle royale all right mark a drop
point for your team
these guys agree we're gonna jump no
one's agreeing i'm just gonna jump on my
own
okay i got one guy on me the other guy
just took off
wish me luck hello you're from poland
hey welcome
to the area watch the skies
all right oh man there's like three
people over there targets are up get to
work
[Applause]
oh my god is a pistol and a prayer let's
go
i need a gun now
oh i'm getting sniped already
oh that's where that's why he was here
come on armor up baby
what is this oh whatever oh there's no
bullets in this but i will
take it anyway wish me luck guys how did
i pick up the bounty there's not a time
for this
oh shoot i knew i saw someone in there
terrible
one plate left
found some smoke oh you know what i've
been mixing up ping because in ping
are in cold war ping is the left d-pad
button
and in war zone it's still for me it's
up because i have a program to up
come on guys these are scattered around
the map if you collect all of them for
the limited time event
and you get a blueprint a special
blueprint
all right let me reload this thing once
again oh to the right to the right
oh no no no no
got one
okay freaking out here
you forget how loud footsteps are
until you go back to modern warfare and
war zone
is it free um this update
for warzone is free yeah
you get a lot more stuff if you happen
to buy cold war
but um right now the warzone experience
that's what you're watching now this
part is free
all right that guy's up here somewhere
what
gas is closing in
there's a guy to my right too um no
i should have focused on the guy to my
right the other guy only had a pistol
can't believe black ops music is in war
zone
it's bs come on man it sounds good it's
classic i got the music pack um
you can even play music out of your car
now in warzone
we have to get to safe zone
tokyo overtaken says on your xbox it's
been laggy
i've heard that for there was a little
bit of lag on the ps5 too i think
i think the developers know and they're
they're i hope there's a hot fix because
uh a lot of people are complaining about
that
i'm just trying to live the gas is
coming in and freaking out there's my
old stuff here's that guy
this thing has no range and i
missed my shot so can't really blame
range
gotta hide gotta hide oh crap
no my friend died you bastard
oh cool he uh re-rezzed aye
right here right in front of us guys
i could really use some armor thank you
enemy uav hectic sorry if i'm not
looking at chat as often but uh
thanks guys for being here this update
is ready to roll across all platforms
i'm playing on the ps5 by the way
[Applause]
frame drop on ps5 yeah i saw frame drops
on ps5 but
not in this mode yet i only saw it in
multiplayer
there's another guy who just went in the
house almost out of bullets what is
what a mess you see this is crazy and i
use my self revive already
yeah uh mr kane this is uh this is the
resurgence mode
uh it's battle royale and wave response
and it's the only way you can play
rebirth island right now so if you've
downloaded the update but can't find the
rebirth island map
you gotta play insurgents
no don't die we got oh hey
we lost that one damn it all right oh
try again
you guys have me until 12 30 so
do i want to quit no game play again
let's see if these guys are my partners
again
how do you get there um are you talking
about the new map
because you got to play resurgence mode
hazir asks do i get more stuff on in war
zone if i have cold war yeah
if you have cold war there are special
blueprints um
you know different skins and um more
characters to unlock
special challenges that can only be
unlocked in cold war and they carry over
to war zone
unbound hey jason hey richie is in the
hizzy
good to see you man
it's always harder when you're playing
with randoms yeah that's true but i had
some good luck
and like i said this mode is much faster
and there's respawning so we all do a
little better you know
but the new map is fun it's just like
you know uh black ops 4 i think
did the same thing they had a small
battle royale map that was
in alcatraz are we streaming only in 720
is that true
i did i didn't notice if that was the
case it shouldn't be
um but yeah this is the ps5 currently
joe max says i prefer you'd prefer a b01
remaster
man i would love to see that but cold
war was fun i think so
they really they really calmed down
because all the you know
uh black ops 3 was a little psycho and
even black ops 2 was a little loco went
into the future
those were fun uh but it's nice to kind
of come back down to earth with the cold
war campaign
and you see all the familiar faces yeah
seagull
this is an alcatraz oh never mind it's
not supposed to be
it's like a replica of where the nova 6
gas was made it's not actually alcatraz
okay jason is saying 1080 60. all right
yeah just check your settings uh i
forgot who said that
if you want to see this in 1080 sounds
like it's available
cool cool thank you guys for being here
battle royale market drop point for your
tape
oh please yeah give this video a like if
you guys are
you know what you can save your likes
for the dub if i ever get it that's fair
oh i'm down to get one okay everyone's
just jumping enemy soldier incoming
um i'm gonna land at this nice looking
building here accepting the white
looks like i got company already
someone already opened oh it's glass
okay targets are up get to work
is this a knife come on
oh boy i hear someone already
ammo for a gun i don't have okay
[ __ ] found the sniper rifle
i need your gun i'm sorry don't self
revive please
ah dig it no no no no
oh goodness i still don't know this map
that well hey my homies are over here
though
[Laughter]
that was dirty i'm sorry i hate the rpg
are my friends alive
[Applause]
i'll take this i need we got to share
this stuff man
enemy uav
oh why do i sell this dragon
off thing
this helicopter the first match i played
of this i got mowed by a helicopter hey
look
the houser from cold war i don't want it
but it's there i'm telling you all the
weapons from cold war are now
in war zones this is insane
okay all right no need for that here
i don't like you camping the
camp camping the crates here
gotta reload uh okay friendly
found a sniper rifle
like those footsteps friendly footsteps
are even too loud and i'm freaking out
hey i'm over here dude
supply stack this is cross play if you
guys uh
my closest friends for uh call of duty
we all play
one's on xbox i'm on playstation another
one two on pc
it's so nice to just have this as an
option any unique thing
before before when it wasn't an option
now it's here baby
all right we're doing okay uh and i
might have just jinxed it by saying that
but we're all alive
and we gotta move we gotta move into the
ring though
holy crap who are you shooting enemies
oh i didn't have enough bullets help me
out oh you punched me to death
this year do i like cold war or war zone
um i really like that they're mixing
right now
but overall i think i like the gameplay
mechanics of
warzone i am enjoying cold war though um
i've been playing a lot of multiplayer
team death match the guns and stuff it's
fun um
uh dirty bomb is okay uh yes i am
playing on
ps5 mr migs but overall uh i think i've
had more fun
with war zones so it's really nice to
see everything just
be included and you know they're kind of
meshed together now it's
pretty great look at that thanks to this
resurgence mode
i'm back oh no
no i don't have anything to defend
myself with except this stupid gun
handgun
oh no
get away get away get away
no don't do it
okay well my friends are still alive
that means i get to come back
sue webb sue hebb i want to say your
name right shout out what up man
thanks for being here nico hey what's
going on man
oh such an honest guy just telling you
how i feel man both
i'm having fun with both games um oh
a loadout drop the contract it's over
oh he was going for the loadout hey i'll
go for the loadout
oh that's his loadout man who has time
to call in
their own ass loadout like he bought one
and called it in i don't have time i
can't even think right now
hey there's the free loadout i'm gonna
pick mine up
um which one should i go though you know
what
a 94 this is my favorite combination you
can hit on the fennick all you want but
it has won me more wars on games than
you'd think
but i'll switch it up to this because
the bruin still rules thank you friend
hey the bounty's in here oh no he moved
up he moved
up he's gonna stop to read here is the
map too small
the map is too small you're losing
ground uh that's part of the fun though
i think i'm having a fun time with it i
don't think it'll get old
because uh verdansk is very big it's a
great memorable map
um you know a little variety is nice
that's all
maybe we get a medium map here oh he's
up here
[ __ ] going for one guy another guy gets
me
that's just that's just how it goes for
me
everyone's in a safe zone
ev asks what's in the new update aside
from this map other than this map
oh my god i have a list up on my screen
there's a lot in this update
um it's a new map
while we wait this is perfect timing
there's a new map throughout season one
there will be five new guns two of them
already here
the mac 10 smg the groza
which is an assault rifle the street
sweeper shotgun which is not it's not
available yet the sledgehammer melee
weapon
a bunch of new maps a bunch of new
gunfight maps gun and
oh i got it can't talk now sorry we're
back
that list is on my screen i will read
more from it later but
the season one update for cold war is
huge
gas is closing in relocating the safe
zone we're still alive no thanks to me
soldier
i don't know i take that back i've
killed three people
my station costs are adjusted no of
course the only
uh the only shop is over can i do it do
i have time
how's the smoke moving forget it i'm
this guy's going i'm going
do i have much money at all okay i don't
have money i don't have money for
anything else who a self-revived kid
let's go the smoke is coming in
there's a gun up ahead excellent
excellent
aaron in the chat yes there is a gondola
on this map i've not used it yet
there's no time sorry this mic should be
good at
downplaying are back my screams
this is a terrifying sentence actually
okay here we go
hello
they're everywhere i need this
this one does have armor yes i'm full on
armor
this is too hectic you guys
someone is upstairs and it's bothering
me
gotta keep it quiet
what do i have as a backup good but i
need something faster
the fennick i'll go with the fennec
oh dead silence no ammo on this
enemy team is tracking your location
this is a mess there are too many guns
here watch the skies
he's running i should have hide yeah i
knew that would happen
yeah this is for you have a nice day
[Music]
olga in the chat with the play-by-play
aka just going no no no
hey we got fifth what am i playing on i
am playing on
uh ps5 right now stepping the triggers
no i'm currently not playing at 4k uh
we're playing at 1080 60.
play again let's go
okay so there are a bunch of updates for
this season
hey i unlock something
what's this oh rebirth island little
logo here
i like mine just okay all right let's
play again resurgence trios
nico says i like how he's just calm
about getting killed yeah
not trying to rage i get mad when it's
like unfair but that i was just
surrounded that's just the name of the
game you know
do cold war guns have the same animation
um as far as
i can tell like it is a little altered
to fit the look of modern warfare
um maybe because i have motion blur on
because uh
i don't know but uh um
the you know the the color palette is
like a little different that's about it
dmc fan i have not played i've been told
to play
uh alessandro and others in the office
have told me
to play devil may cry asap they think i
would love it
the backgrounds are sick yeah this is
the new the new infinite walking
animation here heck yeah
does it play like modern warfare yeah
this is this is still war zone which is
based off the modern warfare engine
so it plays exactly the same there are
just new guns
so that might shake up the meta of the
game but like
that's the same like look looks like i'm
jumping into her dance but it's just a
new map
and new guns have been added from cold
war
dean cruz i don't know if i can answer
that question man i worked at best buy
but
i worked in the tv department i can't i
don't know how to tell if your laptop
was refurbished
enemy soldier tell me okay
did i play god of war have other favor
um i did play a little bit of god of war
that came out when call of duty world
war ii was going on so i played a lot
more of that
um but it's free i got a free copy from
like playstation plus
i started it but i have not finished it
and i know i need to keep dropping into
the io
blake oh i don't know how to answer that
one man um
i don't have the xbox but i've heard
people have had issues all morning with
this update i'm sure there's a
patch of hotfix coming soon
has verdance changed in any way you know
what i haven't played since
uh this morning i haven't played since
don't drop it into the area watch the
skies
i'm tempted to play but you know i want
to show off the new map today so
i don't think i have an answer for you
there
[Music]
comparing warzone and apex there's a lot
of similarities between both and i love
both but
i'm i've been wars i've been stuck on
warzone like this whole year
battle royale all right soldier mark a
drop point for you
antonio hey what's going on
okay why am i always the squad leader
all right let's go to the uh
let's go to this little building jumping
now
heading this way sounds like the homies
are down let's go
is that an og
you pick the wrong roof homeboy
[Applause]
i need your gun give your gun to me
no i don't okay i don't want this pink
one thank you
i'm no good with snipers or semi-autos
in general
sorry okay i gotta take cover pick up
some money
breathe okay
i'm hearing so many upstairs how do we
get
how do we get higher
no i watched him kill my friend finish
the mission
i said it's just me if i survive for 20
seconds
my friend come wait hey hey
oh my goodness if i survive for like a
like 20 seconds or something like that
then my friends come back
look they're back already this is great
they really use their help
hey the collectible box
take this armor up okay
mine active any activision employees i
need a refund
not in this chat not in this chat my
friend just fans of game spot and call
of duty
where's this box it's killing me it's
got to be above us whoa whoa whoa whoa
that sounds really close
[Applause]
i'm hearing oh there he is
sorry friend
have i said that already legion says i
hate black ops come on
well at least there are black ops is
moving its way into uh war zone my
friend i'm sorry
sorry you're not a fan but it happens
that guy here
where you hiding from bro someone is
pinging
way too much
what do you want me to do pick up your
laundry
you know i'm gonna stop messing with
this guy and see what's going on
upstairs
i'm wait
why does he have bullet icon on him i
don't know what that means right here
watch
okay you scared the [ __ ] out of me
all this talking got our friend killed
oh someone is downstairs look at the uav
get pick up this ammo real quick enemy
uav overhead
okay
you have eyes on all right going down
going down wait for me
that sounds upstairs what is going on
here
i think it's downstairs despite how it
sounds ooh
i knew it oh friendly god
daniel says i'm updating now can't wait
yes hop in
27th place no 10th place
i forget how to read that up top yeah
we're in a good spot for now
we're gonna have to switch
i was just talking up this location
[Applause]
oh my god come on guys
gas is inbound marking new safe zone can
we make it there there's no time
someone's coming
you're probably above us be careful
sorry ah don't sell for vibe
i'm sorry got you guys got enough armor
take the armor
hey by the way i'm playing with the ffar
from cold war this is insane
okay i want to read the chat so bad
because you guys are cool but uh i'm
freaking out right now let me let me
hide here for a sec
can i jump in with you uh i think we can
get a match going i'm just playing with
random so
if you want to watch addicted says
painful to watch good [ __ ] man thanks
for being
here be sure to drop a like
i mean look i got four kills we're still
alive it's not that bad right
need high caliber rounds you need high
caliber rounds
uh here i'll drop some wait
yeah i have an infinite is that what
that guy wanted for me earlier
large caliber round skier uh
enemy all cx-1 i'll take him i'll i'll
find him later
don't go on without me hey we're in this
together friends
ooh dead silence yeah what's this
what's my backup i will take
the bison over the uh
what's it called oh my god i'm blanking
positive id on the bounty target sort
them out
enemy uav overhead the ffar is good but
right now it's got 25 bullets and that's
not
enough watch our ride over here boys
it's too quiet over here
jungle oh you're losing ground frog out
i see him one's over there can i jump
down here yes i can
oh god oh thank you so much
oh you know i got i got to read that
later this is oh
i don't want to die while uh while
representing gamespot but thank you for
your kind words
this is insane it's too much yes what's
minus two
what's that mean don't
okay cool i was like don't come back to
life please
take all this stuff
oh i can breathe okay are there
duplicate weapons like the sks on the
p29
uh pp19 uh i haven't tried that yet but
yeah people were wondering though if you
can dual wheel you know like
the mp5 from the cold war and the mp5
from modern warfare i have not tested
that out yet
that's a good question that would be a
well broken oh was that your stuff i
think i stole some of our teammates
stuff
people are on that dude i'm scared uh
maybe if i take the lower ground here
doesn't seem like anyone's over here
wait
wait oh i changed my mind
get to the new safe zone anything for me
homeboy
you know in cold war you can swim so the
second match i tried i jumped in the
water and you just died because this is
war zone you can't swim in a war zone
and i died like a juventus
no we're pinned here boys i can't swim
across there
all right do we all have enough armor
and there's a threat on us
alex says you're the best you're crazy
thanks man thanks for being here
word says okay this is not splinter cell
get the heartbeat monitor did i leave it
down there
head for target location that is
disregarded yes
good call out thank you
rebirth what soon
enemy uav overhead all right we're
moving up we're moving up
keep a low profile
it appears i can't do can't stream in
chat at the same time
i missed the whole fire sale and i
didn't even know what was going on
fortunately
oh thank you our lord and savior game
spot chimed in
that's probably eric
come on pick up uh yeah i need a second
one
dude you guys we're 10th again it's
looking it's looking mm-hmm
i won't say i won't say anything else
other than that repositioning
my own teammates are scaring me all
right let me let me stop and breathe
here for a sec
how you guys doing heartbeat monitor yes
i do have it
intense new mod
do the cold war weapons feel different
in war zone so far not that i've noticed
uh they've
did a great job of switch bringing over
the cold war
meta over to war zone it's
so surprising uh everyone was wondering
for you know
months how they were going to make this
integration happen and i think it's
going well
new safe zone located hope we'll see you
playing battlefield 6 in 2021
how many headshots so far zero my friend
i don't go for headshots but
that's cause uh i'm a console scrub baby
someone is up there for sure
five teams left 13 people i've got seven
kills
location watch this roof though that's
where they were shooting us from
all right all right oh goodness
did you get him
i gotta reload this i didn't have to but
wait there is no time
[Music]
you know what let's step it up is this a
bounty oh it's a supply you've got gas
moving in
oh guys i can't breathe
the closest i've made it was second
place before the stream of course
i got second and i died to the gas
i'm about to die to the gas right now we
gotta move up
okay these guys are good at pinging this
is great
yes xp crosses over between cold war and
war zone this is
nuts and even modern warfare like what
this is the future baby
hell no should have plugged that in from
the start
um no ma'am
what is this oh i've heard about this i
don't have the code
gotta nope yeah i had to try
oh my god this is the final circle part
two
i'm gonna get shot i know it i know it
it's too open hey the gondola
oh
hopefully my teammates can clutch it i
am now spectating
oh my god i left my buddy
did the r90 get nerfed no it didn't
again nope
the uh not that i know of uh alex i'm
playing on ps5
station did you like that passcode i
had to give it a shot you know they're
cheeky monkeys
stay blessed
wait points marked move can you move
faster in cold war with the cold war
loadout
that's an interesting question so far no
i think it's still based i think
movement speed
no don't make me watch this
i can't skip i can leave all right all
right hats off to these guys they just
outgunned us
how do you play on rebirth um you have
to play the resurgence mode that's the
only way you play reverb island right
now it's a trio's mode
of warzone where you can respawn it's
pretty fun that's what i'm playing right
now
why is the hud so close should i move it
down
second ah the biggest l there is play
again though let's do it
which is your favorite in modern warfare
gunfight and snd uh i don't play search
into story much because uh
i gotta have my respawns but uh gunfight
is fun
when i'm playing with a friend um
see here oh yeah let's try again oh yeah
see the only way to play
rebirth island again resurgence mode
trios
what i unlock a handgun upgrade
oh just a camo no
see here's the mac 10 which is which was
only in cold war but
uh it launched actually just launched
today and it's in cold war and
war look at see the dorito chip on there
got that for free from doritos check out
there check out mountain dew's twitter
you get that little
dorito chip for free okay let's try this
again
oh if you guys want to look around here
sure like here it is it you know
the rebirth is a limited time mode just
like the halloween one if you get 16
boxes around the map you get that
blueprint up there
um mr kane says use the female
soldiers next year i got it on random
but i got you watch this look here's the
layout now there's stitch
we can go with uh we can go with park
let's go park that's not park
what the [ __ ] what
what's going on here it's goofing up a
little bit
using the rpg or the rpg from black ops
hmm all right let's just jump into
another game whatever's on the ground i
got to pick it up you know that's how
that's how war zone goes
hey that's not my operator of choice
i said pick park
there we go okay resurgence trios park
is uh have you guys played the
cold war campaign yet she's one of the
main good guys depending on how you look
at it
are there any um cod points
other than getting the battle pass not
that i know of
i mean you just gotta like buy them i
think
is this royale yes this is a smaller
battle royale new map on warzone
called rebirth island
what's your favorite single player game
um it's been a while since i played like
a good
you know like i've loved the last of us
god of war
uh the uncharted series is good but you
know those are all like old school i
haven't played
a good single player story game
this year they're out there for charges
like i haven't played go sushima yet i
there's a lot
peter what peter valley says park is hot
all right
get yourself sorted we'll be deployed
shortly
how does the mp5 differ um i've played
i've been playing cold war
and the mp5 in cold war has um like
minor changes
but they're pretty much i think the
damage is higher
on the mp5 in modern warfare
uh but geez the the fire rate is faster
i think in cold war i might be screwing
up these facts but
just from from what i remember from what
i've noticed
you guys gonna download this map let me
know
oh also you guys you guys are having fun
having fun hanging out with me leave a
little like on that video
it makes me look good you know what i'm
saying
last of us old school um
last of us did i say it was old school
all right i guess i did uh because you
know i got it on the playstation three
part part one you know
part two eventually uh came out like
last year but
um part one for me was more memorable
that's probably hot dog
alex appreciate the love man
yeah i mean reading the comments is what
it's all about you know i don't i'm not
streaming for my enjoyment it's for you
guys you guys are here we're all just
hanging out
you could like i said you can go play
this right now for free but you're here
with me so that means a lot thank you
guys
does warzone have a campaign no the
story from warzone was actually
an extension of the modern warfare story
so you gotta play that
you crazy
oh brandon yes i got my hands on the mac
10 and i made a class i shouldn't have
but
i picked up a mac 10 from royal
if i find one it's on that thing is a
bullet hose
that's a bounty contract we got we got
company
bouncy target is up let's get it started
[Music]
this is insane oh my god get out of here
oh my god it's down to me already
friends i'm gonna hide
i have to hide until i find a better gun
if i stay alive my teammates come back
that's how it works
does the movement feel slower no it's
war zone it feel if you've played war
zone it's the same
um cold war guns have been added but
not every mechanic from the cold war oh
my god
this is what i'm talking about right
here little patience pays off my friends
are back
one guy left oh no yeah if i find a mac
10 i promise i'll use it
i want to find the mac 10. instead i'm
finding all these
goddamn snipers
in here somewhere look at this the rpd
baby
all right this down he's gonna get it
this blast keeps hitting my doors
okay the bounty has moved check it out
though baby the rpd
officially you know you can kind of
forge one in um modern warfare get out
of here
i'm giving away my position so that's
probably not smart but um
i got one homie here left someone's up
here
this thing is steady i'm no good but
like that was still cool
i need to armor up what am i doing
just a friendly just a friendly
words is like run words welcome back man
i remember that name
it's good to have you on okay
let me breathe a little bit here the
bouncy target is down
well done hey someone else killed the
bounty and we made money
oh i hear footsteps i'm freaking out
already this gun has slow ads
i need to be prepared
playing oh see what i'm talking about
come on wait i'll heal you come over
here no
an airstrike oh they're killing my
friend
i'm a terrible teammate i got my tail
between my legs i'm just
freaking out oh i'm there's so many open
doors
oh it's at the mac 10. it's
on the baby look at this mac 10 it's
here it's fast
it's it's a little beast oh
that abs oh yeah oh yeah
is modern warfare part of uh there's
warzone part of
modern warfare yeah they're in the same
like universe for sure
um cold war is forcing its way into that
universe but
technically it's not the same storyline
as far as i know unless they start
integrating it
it's weird to see everybody here in one
game
what's up stop camping hey i'm trying to
talk to you guys i'm not camping
all right i'm camping a little bit [ __ ]
contact contact
she took the words right out of my mouth
i gotta use this mac 10 at close range
you guys need to see it so
i'm just keeping a low profile you've
got a loadout drop inbound
you know the rule if i'm doing this it's
not camping
oh they killed my friend again all right
get it done
he's right out there isn't he i hate
that two-story building all right close
it get to the new safe zone
yep i knew it oh what they're right
behind me now
can you just leave me alone
one armor plate okay sick give me that
you know exactly where i am i might be
toast
or if they shoot me through this tent
i'm toast
getting the hell out of here that's one
thing i really miss about
war zone is super spring it's here it's
back i've been playing a lot of
cold war that has no super sprint
whatever i'll take this just give me
something oh a decoy
okay this could be useful in a time like
this
my friend left yeah not my friend my
teammate
he dipped it's just me guys
oh god
jason if you dare thumbs down this video
i'll still love you
okay i am in between a rock and a hard
place with some
some decent guns but i'm scared and i'll
end alone
oh boy what cod has the best campaign i
really like modern warfare
two and three uh black ops one also
an excellent campaign in my opinion what
do you guys think
oh and uh uh 2019 modern warfare was
really good
really memorable
i'm it's too quiet over here i'm really
scared
someone's gonna snipe me from there i'm
i gotta i gotta
do something zero kills i don't know
dude
my friends died and they left and i'm
freaking out okay there's one guy over
here
get mark bro hey he's all alone too okay
he's all alone i might just go for it
let me ping him one more time oh
no oh
i'll start off in your eye out okay oh
well
okay
should i either i'm not gonna attack if
there were one guy i would attack him
but you know i'm a wimp and i'm alone so
i'm gonna actually hide from them
bust out the mac 10. look at all these
guns dude
that's a that is a great question why i
have zero kills i don't know what's
going on man i'm just running and hiding
i'm scared okay oh no no
this is my
hey only 25 remain
guys this is nuts i finally
i've had how long have i had armor
yes another mac 10. oh it's the milano i
don't want two smgs
gas is moving in sights you know what
that means
wait hold on hold on people are gonna
come up from this
fire hill is active my station costs are
adjusted
that guy was sniping me he's gonna have
to come up this hill and i'm ready
i'm ready
wait here more
i did see that guy oh he went for a
loadout i'm
capital enemy uav
armor yeah thank you guys i put on armor
[Music]
freaking out mack ten times
enemy uav overhead quit throwing up the
uav you're exposing me
you guys remember the mac 11 was in i
think the first black ops
oh my god where'd that guy go
[Laughter]
i love that you can
uh hey look check out the gun he's got
the xm4 aka the commando
he bested me what are you gonna do play
again
what time is it okay cool you guys we
have another half hour let's go
how are we doing in chat
thank you guys all for being here this
is a great way to start the day huh
how do you play rebirth uh you have to
play the only way you can play it is
through resurgence mode
um you can't play through regular battle
royale like you
that's only for dance right now as far
as i know
i bet he got an mp5 now they're here
maybe yeah gosh this is like it's such a
rush that i forget to like
buy a you know care package i'm not
hitting up the shop like i normally do
the pace is so much faster
target practice while you can crazy
jason if you've got the update man let's
do it
i could use a teammate i'm playing with
randoms i think you guys know already
uh but i can't chat on the mic my setup
right now is
unchattable
okay well good thing it's only practice
mode
where'd he go oh that guy shot me from
over here okay whatever
practice mode will modern warfare get
new content
i'm not sure they uh it went from season
six of modern warfare to season one
of cold war so i don't know if uh
you can still cross progress and they're
gonna support that game but as far as
new original content for modern warfare
i'm not sure in fact
i don't think so could be me you know
whatever that game was so successful i
think they should
keep supporting it and adding content
but um
you know that's my opinion cold war is
currently right now
is there a gulag no not in this version
um
i'm waiting for the regular battle
royale
of rebirth island to happen i don't know
if there will be one
phantom bolt should be 60 frames per
second
okay cool jason next game
i will invite you you got to make
yourself i got to be able to find your
gondola marked
oh there's a bunch of stuff here let's
go let's go let's go
located a supplier
supply run is that an enemy ooh
i do not want that currently there's
another box below oh armor armor good
good good
yes i am playing on the playstation 5.
the update is live friends this is crazy
my friends okay they're nearby good good
good
i was gonna say like don't abandon me oh
no you monster
contact contact this is stupid okay good
that's a friendly
i was gonna say the stupid swap time was
horrendous
one plato armor okay
give me this instead no not that this
[Applause]
i hear footsteps guys be careful our guy
no they're both back good good good
xd and you're io yeah
tango hostile dropping into the area
they're on the floor above me and um i'm
letting them die so i'm gonna go up
there
this is you can only play trios right
now by the way
[Applause]
how did i let him die i'm such a shitty
teammate
well at least i got that other guy but
at what cost you know what i'm saying
and now i'm hearing all these footsteps
i'm freaking out and i'm alone wait okay
they're back
switch that over no i kind of like this
one okay
enough talk they're on the roof i can't
get to the roof and i don't think i want
to go to the roof
[ __ ] in the open
all right move we're still on mission
don't just inbound
okay i gotta armor up hide armor up
oh goodness there's an enemy team
you want me to play the original modern
warfare app like for dansk
i don't know i mean um i could i don't
know if any changes have been made to it
oh that's why okay he was hanging out
that was a lot like me in the last game
remember when i was all alone
cold war has a field of vision slider
does this i don't know i haven't tried
that yet
i don't think so it's uh it's still the
modern warfare [ __ ]
is that my old gun
hey i'm playing with my lag oh my
goodness
to be quiet
60 frames per second good yes that's
what i'm playing on uh my monitor is not
120 so i can't max that out but
you've got a loadout drop inbound it's
looking it still looks good in 60 frames
to me how about you
okay oh ammo
wait there are dudes on top of the roof
freaking out i'm freaking out closing
get to the new safe zone oh they're here
wait who killed them come over here
oh my god come here i'm not gonna revive
you from there you're gonna get me
killed
come here destination mocked oh my god
oh my god come here my lag what are you
doing over there
i need
i'm screwed trophy system active come on
my lag you just need to come over here
my dude
oh my god you're gonna give me kill i
hate you
oh i hate you you're on your own chief
why did it stop asking questions
just do it oh he threw c4 don't like
that
let me uh there's no door
oh my god okay is he back yet i need
help
i'm freaking out
we are in the top ten we're sixth place
where's that box
i don't have armor
[Applause]
if if they are yeah hell yeah over this
i'm doing some real claw maneuvers right
now guys my hands are cramping i'm a
real gamer
i'm freaking out where's my friend
they're both on the other side of the
well
looks like i just got to hang back
i hear them i hear them oh my god i hear
them
i hear them in two places
okay asmr time gamer edition everyone be
quiet
oh they're upstairs again okay maybe
i'll go upstairs
quietly oh no i already used that one
okay
oh there's so many staircases everyone's
in this every soldier incoming oh my god
oh my god
oh my god see this is what that guy the
other guy was doing he was camping just
like me
i'm alone and scared
oh my god he's right here he's got to be
right
have eyes here you guys playing around
too much
oh my god oh my god
your footsteps everywhere
i cracked him that's it
he's arming up right now i screwed that
up
this is a terrible game of cat and mouse
guys i'm freaking out
my friends are getting closer though
this is good
that's a good gun too
oh my goodness move out
no hello me no i can't i'm scared gotta
wait till my friends late
i'm moving around too much in fact
friendly uav overhead they're above me
that's the issue another box do these
keep
popping back up oh armor enemy uav
yes
enemy uav okay now the gas is moving i'm
forced to be uav
get out of the house mohammed leave it
alone i'm freaking out on my wall
back to normal all right fine enemy uav
over here i'm moving but you guys are
gonna get me killed
look at there are three people in this
building how about i hang out right here
enemy uav over here oh
someone close that door someone is
nearby hmm
you are going to die thank you yes
[Laughter]
that much that much is clear but
hopefully
it's via entertainment
this is what happens when i go outside
bro
me too yeah visuals um the footsteps are
so loud in the voice
they're helpful
this is what happens hey but my
teammates are alive let's see let's see
how they do
they clean up
well nope
[Music]
okay let me back out get a buddy in
let's do it
can i join your game see if this yes
excellent playing with the homie jason
where you at this dog there he is
of course he's dressed like a jigsaw
move out or russian man
i normally rush in like multiplayer but
warzone is a different beast man i'm
scared i'm scared all the time
but i'm getting advice in the chat don't
hide i need to hunt
yeah see the roof i hate uh there's a
lot of lines on the alcatraz map
and like more than ever um well downtown
in for dance goes a lot too but you know
what i mean
it's crazy it's crazy
okay we're searching for a lobby let me
see what i unlocked here
there's the mac 11 i unlocked a barrel
hell yeah look how small this thing is
it's a beast though i had good luck with
it this morning
what else did i unlock what is this well
the mp5
uh camo hmm no thanks
okay we got a game going let's go
oh it's very late for you a leon alien
i don't want to mispronounce your name
but it's late please get some rest thank
you for being here
thank you so much and hopefully i'll see
you again sometime soon
get yourself sorted stream until i get a
dub man i'll be here all day
just kidding hopefully with jason the
homie jason is out on my team
let's get this dub
you sir thank you thank you and good
night
have a nice day
holy crap thanks woods
see why can i why can't i like slay like
this
never mind take that back
mr kane i'm sorry i don't think i'll be
playing the verdance map today
we're just trying to show off the
rebirth map
maybe some other time um
i do have to confirm if big changes have
been made to that map
what the
wow forget the crossbow bro i'd rather
just use my hand
time for the real thing why is the
amazing spider-man
one and two not in stores what you're in
the wrong place my friend i don't have
an answer for that
all right oh what we don't have a third
okay it didn't fill us in with the third
great
it's okay battle royale
drop point for your team your leader i
know this map that way
oh small enough i'm getting to know this
man let's go somewhere far away and safe
jason let's go
wish me luck guys it's only two of us in
a trio's match but
here's hoping ooh an rpd that i missed
hunting me bro i just gotta do it
homies down i think he's on the roof oh
no
yes smart thinking you'll feel better in
a sec
yes okay
they're coming around jason get ready
oh she should scare the [ __ ] out of me
that costume doesn't help either
what do i have is a backup my handgun
okay
they're around here somewhere
oh it's another door okay some cash some
ammo if you need it bro
what about this door huh
all right jason my friend here is doing
what you guys want he is he is out and
about he has
no he's not a camper
aka says we waited a year for this
bro don't be a hater you play cold war
oh
he needs oh shoot let me uh let me drop
this for a friend here you need both of
these dude
go get that armor
go okay
just keeping it quiet opening doors i'm
not slamming them open
claymore yeah i'll take it no i like the
molotov better
okay i hate being so low though i think
we should
oh they're right up there okay let's get
to some higher ground
i see him
there's one in my left oh goodness
gracious this wall is too short i
couldn't
andres man lighten up man
[ __ ] headley is out andres is out
hey wasn't this in black ops 4 yes it
was um they called it something else i
don't know if they called it the rebirth
map but you know
they took the mob of the dead map which
was also alcatraz
keep it together threw it in a war zone
no way jason is here to save the day
yes thank you thank you thank you let me
get the hell out of here i have no armor
okay we've been here already let me
prepare
we're too low man this stinks we need to
get to higher ground
quietly
someone in the chat says i just
downloaded this let's go
hope you enjoy friend that gondola
scared the s
hmm okay i don't think anyone's raided
this building yet good news good news
here it is
rpd here is moving in safe zone located
need more armor for me and jason
okay good we're getting the higher
ground though this is good news
doesn't look like anyone's raided this
area no
i should have dropped that for you jason
my bad
it's over here
okay okay and that's the outside okay
oh goodness oh goodness gracious
oh nice you found a red box what's my
backup enemy uav
overhead um what do i want
milano's good but the fire rate is kind
of slow i think i'll stick with this
oh boy
wait no jason you take that you need it
i got two plates you got zero but i'll
take this
see what's in here though are you
getting sniped are you sniping
uh enemy uav overhead
okay i'll apply my last bit of armor
here
i don't have a sniper i'm gonna hide
over here
is that gas i'll take it yep jason's
getting hit okay
from where
ping him if you see him jason oh oh it's
a gondola
that needs to be destroyed i hate that
thing
where are they shooting you from oh
goodness
uh currently me thinks it's it's only in
the respawning mode
i see him destination mocked uh you can
only play this in the respawning mode
resurgence
just when i switch to semi-auto to pick
at those guys here comes ghost
hunter be hunted yeah you're right look
at this guy
we have the mp5
it's okay we can play again i think
we've got uh time for
one or two more so let's give it a go if
you're still down
oh boy what a morning what time is it
where you guys live
for us here on the west coast it is 12
19 p.m
some of you guys it's like late at night
or it's like the future it's tomorrow
try using the rcxd dang it i forgot i
had it
i should have that thing you can jump
with it there's a if you press
x it jumps
nate i'm having fun i think it's good i
don't know what
everyone at chat thinks but uh the new
map is fun
uh resurgence mode is fun too it's a lot
more forgiving
everyone's saying they're disappointed
and i don't know i mean
verdance was such a good big map and
rebirth island is like the exact
opposite so it might not be your play
style
probably why people might be
disappointed
all right it's a party over here
[Music]
219 seth
wait someone's over here
eastern asia it's about 4 20 a.m oh man
wow thanks for watching mr kane
the only way to play on rebirth island
right now is through the
resurgence game mode you can't just pick
battle royale
um resurgence game mode has respawns
and trios only currently battle royale
market for your table okay good we got a
third this time
moving to destination here we go hostile
dropping into the area watch the skies
people like your position
a gondola hit me
[Applause]
okay good good but i need a gun
being quiet
great cluster strike oh man our friend
got hit
okay okay okay okay where do you get hit
from
he's back it's okay
those helicopters i think have gunners
now those are scary
so i'm gonna stay away from that dudes
up ahead though if you want to
move my friends
i won can i see him from here damn it
it's gonna revive
all right i think i should go back to my
friends where they are
did it mean to kick that door open
there's a box oh
shop next objective located
uav or i have enough armor gas
you moving you're coming here with me
okay cool cool cool
i'll go this way never mind that
all supply box is found
okay not bad so far
oh mr king says i wake up at midnight
night owl mode
one of my teammates has the clan tag
fart so i think i'm in good hands
i think i used fart for years
okay hmm all right
you've got a loadout drop in there
for sure let's do this a 94 ak
as val maybe the good old m4 and then
i'll pick up uh
this other gun as my backup yeah yeah
yeah
two m4s love it
the only oh if you want to play the new
mode or the new map you have to play the
resurgence mode uh you can't play
regular warzone oh crap up here guys
target confess they're far away all
right never mind maybe i'll just hang
back
hmm don't want that
okay excuse me
okay just scoping out the area i got the
uav but i don't need to use it just yet
i don't think
there's the houser again once again from
black ops
i don't want it because i don't need a
shotgun right now but
moving you see a bad guy you're just
moving up
drop headed your way
oh oh there's a two-story building okay
if we approach that building we gotta
take it easy
tank just out of everything moving in
new safe zone located
oh yes i am playing as a character from
cold war i'm playing as uh park
as requested by the chat
these guys like to hang back too
i mean that's how i used to play apex my
friends and i were all like
we all like to hang back and load up on
loot and then uh
try to win at the final fight
smg smg now i like my guns currently
i'm scared of that building up ahead um
it's it's like it feels like modern
warfare movement still to me someone in
the chat asks
if it's a cold war movement or
not a warfare movement and it's still
warzone so i think it's
the way it feels it still just feels
like playing warzone with new guns added
okay where are we in the ring okay this
is a very
this is probably the slowest match i've
played
heading in not a bad thing just other
ones are so spicy
all right i do want to move to higher
ground so i'm going to start
cluster strike maybe after this
the new playlist is in the main menu of
war zone yeah um right below battle
royale you pick resurgence mode
and that's how you can play rebirth
island
hmm spotter scope no
[ __ ] oh it just came back they do
respawn this is great
great great great
all right me and my homies are just
hanging back maybe i'll press on a
little bit
enemy uav overhead gas is inbound i have
ghost on or uh uh
cold-blooded both actually so i'm gonna
slowly move up
if i die i can respond that's fun enemy
uav overhead
oh this is such a small here we go
the persia yeah she uh she is busy this
week but uh everyone's in the safe zone
that'd be fun it's been a while since we
streamed together
enemy uav they were all working from
home you know
what's that someone's been up there i
think okay
look like debris came down all right i'm
gonna keep it cool keep it quiet
move up though i can't be hanging back
the whole time
nothing in here okay some bodies
flipping the only way to play the new
rebirth map is through the resurgence
game mode it's resurgence trios
so it's not exactly classic battle
royale
you get respawns and you get trios only
that's the only way to play it right now
someone's head
no
oh gas is moving in new safe zone
location i'm kind of far from my friends
i don't like
all right all right moving moving moving
looks like they got him
cool let's go shopping
wait let me check the window first
someone
last time i tried a fire sale someone
shot me
it happens armor box
yeah let's do it hit up this uav and buy
a cheap one right now uav entering the
ao
all right very good
you guys you should hit up the shop hit
up the shop where is it meow
vendor marked we got a few seconds left
these guys are calm cool and collected
tommy yes this is the new map this is
the new
um let me zoom out here the new alcatraz
rebirth rtb for resupply
and the only way to play it resurgence
you got to play the resurgence game mode
it's not
in regular battle royale right now here
i go
okay i made some good progress earlier
trying to get up there now i'm scared to
do it again
because these guys my friends my
teammates they like to hang back
maybe i'll try creeping up there again i
can't be here the whole time you guys
you guys got to see the map
at the risk of me dying
[Applause]
oh oh boy enemy uav overhead
smoke grenade
oh no mr cowboy where did he come from
see you guys
rudy has entered the chat
okay jared you said i missed alcatraz
it's back man and it's free
let's see if my teammate can hang it uh
keep it together
they're both alive okay good good i have
a good shot i think it's a max of
40 players i forget it was it was
something less than like way less than
100.
there is no gulag in this resurgence
mode which sucks because
a new gulag will be introduced soon i
think there's actually one going on
in verdansk like normal but um
oh you know what
i can't do both i can't do both so now
that i'm dead
these guys don't i hope they don't
oh but the new gulag system is uh is
similar to the old one
uh if you play in verdansk there is a
you're strapped to a chair like in black
ops one
you unstrap yourself and then you uh go
find your 1v1 opponent opponent
and there are metal detectors so if
you're running around too much they'll
go off they'll know where to find you
um but
cowboy guy yes
but i haven't seen that yet because
resurgence mode when i'm playing now
doesn't have glove you can respond
that's why
these dudes are hanging the f out
claymore watch out smoke watch out
please get out of here boys oh my god
those guys on the roof dude there's ones
who got me the car's gonna blow up
okay
i don't know how they haven't died yet
they're well they're down but like
they did pretty great dodging some of
those
mr kenya i think it is like an updated
version of the alcatraz map from black
ops
[Applause]
well it is time though so
ending on an l but
here we go okay guys thank you so much
for joining me this afternoon if you
liked
hanging out today leave a like and be
sure to check out all of our other call
of duty game spot
our videos on gamespot.com and on
youtube
thanks for hanging out and i'll see you
guys next time bye